gonna knock this dude out he's gonna
fight this guy right and you got and
you're so drunk you're
you're wobbling you're like okay and i'm
blacked out you're blacked out you threw
a
full-on swing at this fool right he
didn't move you missed him
and then you spun around and you fell on
the floor and the guy was like
but you were so drunk and because i
wasn't there with you
you were there earlier either it was
with like some seattle friends or you
were with somebody else oh
[ __ ] i remember seeing you and then in
five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode
of the genius brain god damn it
god damn it genius
we've been drinking man pandemic has
caused me to drink a lot more than i
normally do but i don't drink like how i
used to though i sip now
yeah and it's the only time i drink is
when i come here
the only time i drink is my podcast yeah
that's right specifically
yeah because drinking by yourself is
[ __ ] sad
it's pretty sad dude don't remind me of
those days
you should drink a lot by yourself
sometimes man i just
go this is what i do i'd get a [ __ ]
big ass
like costco jug of crown
and just drink it by yourself yeah in
seattle and like one time okay dan
wasn't even a test
he borrowed my car once and then he came
back and he found
this bottle of north korean soju that my
sister got me from north korea
i don't remember why i was still in
there and then um
an empty bottle crown too he's like dude
i think you have a problem
dude do you remember when a bunch of
people came over to the apartment for a
party
yeah and then somebody smoked your north
korean cigarettes yeah
i'm like damn man like
come on like it's like they didn't they
were just
in your room and they just started
smoking cigarettes out your [ __ ]
window
yeah and clearly these aren't normal
cigarettes yeah they're
north korean cigarettes they look like
[ __ ] and they're pretty shitty too they
taste like [ __ ] too
yeah and but it was like that's
specifically why i know how much was in
there yeah because they taste like [ __ ]
so i didn't smoke them after
but i kept them at souvenirs because my
sister [ __ ] went to north korea to
get him
yeah yeah and i couldn't believe just
like man you know what maybe we should
have less parties
but i don't understand why they just
went to your [ __ ] room i think it was
one of the few smoking areas because
there was that
fire escape out oh yeah people love
smoking there because the view
yeah i have at least had that view out
that way yeah that ninth floor view in
cape town was pretty dope
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was [ __ ]
weird that day
what party was that for dude we have so
many parties though
yeah like i don't know you know what's
funny
we were we were just talking about this
weird situation where um
so there was a show called k-town cal
i think it was k-town it was just called
k-town right it wasn't k-town cowboys
right
it was called k-town and um there's a
couple of cast members
i don't i don't i never watched that
show yeah right i didn't know but i i
think my buddy
our buddy eddie he was the one that
executive producer or whatever right
never trashed that show in front of him
out of respect for him but that show is
trash
eddie you're a good man i [ __ ] love
you but if that was your crown
jewel of a moment in your life you need
to redo your life because that shit's
was [ __ ] weird
so i did the audition tape for one of
the cast members because he's my hung
from seattle oh and
eddie hit me that's how i first met him
i was in
i was at dan's house and i get a phone
call he's like yo uh joe chuck
or [ __ ] that's fine he's on the show
he's on the show he gave me your number
and it was like that you want to work on
the show do you want to be
you know one of the filmers directors
editors on the show you'll help us
produce this
and i was like nah like cause just
making the audition tape to make it so
jersey shorey for asians
i did i knocked it out the park but like
i was like i don't want to make like
10 episodes of this [ __ ] you know that's
essentially what the show was it was
it was the jersey shore the koreatown
version of it right yeah
and the idea was was like well who wants
to see more asians play violin or
do you excel in these things we know the
idea was
just be trashy and be okay with being
trashy yeah you know
like the idea was and this is that's the
thing that every cast member
like because i i met a bunch of them
because through making this audition
tape
they all know what it is exactly but
they want they're being a part of it be
like
ultimately we're not in a box of this
minority myth yeah this was ten years
ago yeah they were saying we get [ __ ]
up and we do stupid [ __ ] too
i think the weird thing about that show
was that it was like
are these fools even from [ __ ] k-town
i think maybe a couple of a couple of
them yeah they're not even
[ __ ] from k-town you have any there's
way better trash bags in cape town
all right you guys aren't even really
dumb could have been on that show
don could have been on that show easy
dude but you know he would never be on
that show though
yeah i mean but so one of the one of the
guys i think he was a cast member but
this dude i
[ __ ] hated this dude so much um so
during so we had a bunch of movie
posters that you guys
yeah right and you guys got it from when
blockbusters were shut down yeah so we
bought all these [ __ ] movie posters
yeah so these are like legit movie
posters you can't really buy these
anywhere
they're printed on the [ __ ] canvas
like and it's not like a regular canvas
it's like this wooden canvas it's like
painted
it's vintage it's really [ __ ] dope
right and
lo and behold there was uh one of the
batman posters were missing
yeah and so what happened was
i just happened to be drunk at that
party
and just because we this party
specifically was the move-in party
we were like we were like hey we just
moved to k-town and like [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of people showed up
i remember this at least i'm drunk and
i'm looking at the posters like wow it's
nice to be here and i'm like
where's that [ __ ] batman poster like
that poster is legit
like it was like what the [ __ ] and one
of the cast members
i see him and his friend walking out the
door carrying the
[ __ ] poster in his this is a
27 by 34 poster it's huge it's huge man
where you think you're
[ __ ] huge i literally caught him out
the door and snatched it on his head i
was like bro where are you going with
this
yeah he's like ah man it was a joke no
it was not you're at the door man
yeah you're out the door and i just went
back in and
shut the door yeah so this little tells
me that [ __ ] and i'm
getting [ __ ] mad right i'm getting
infuriated right because you don't steal
[ __ ] from people come on at our house
at our housewarming party he's trying to
steal some of our [ __ ]
right and you guys already know if you
guys didn't grow up in a nice area you
steal from somebody's [ __ ] some shit's
gonna pop off right yeah i'm not saying
i'm a thug or anything else but
i was livid right i'm like this [ __ ]
thinks that he could
[ __ ] push us over because we're some
[ __ ] nice guys yeah so i saw that
dude at taubang
and i went up to him i was like hey are
you the dude they try to [ __ ] jack my
[ __ ]
right it wasn't even it was his poster
yeah
what's up bro you know and i literally
was in this dude's face abe was there
and everything's like
[ __ ] dave's going to get into
fighting this bar yeah this guy i [ __ ]
you [ __ ] not
out of nowhere starts crying
he starts crying starts
bawling his eyes out and now it's just
awkward right and he's like yo man like
we're homies
you know he's like i just want us to be
friends i'm like oh he this guy's on
coke
like the [ __ ] out
he's bawling in front of me crying in
this bar
yo man i don't want me to hold me to the
top before we friends right and i'm like
i'm not your friend that's what i said i
don't even [ __ ] know you dude
i was like bro don't ever step into my
place and i just kind of left it at that
but this guy was crying in front of me
so
either he was coming down from a high
but he was definitely on drugs
and that's the type of human beings we
will let in our apartment yeah
[Laughter]
such a weird [ __ ] day i hated that
guy those
those days at the apartment we have so
many weird stories people coming in and
out
even inviting one person okay remember
when i invited one girl
over and she showed up with six random
dudes
oh my god do you remember and you were
laying on the couch watching tv
and they showed up and i'm like i was
talking like who the [ __ ] are these
people or whatever
i'm like what are you talking i do you
want to hang out you and me
who are these people because she'd come
up before she saw we had a big place
yeah and people the wrong things like
because it happened to a lot of people
people thought our joint was the [ __ ]
headquarters of k-town
yeah come hang out here yeah and they
just show up i remember you were laying
down
and this [ __ ] kid took a seat to
watch tv but your
feet were at the end of the couch too
and i was like david is not gonna move
yep david is not literally staring at
him you're just staring
like you weren't even watching tv
anymore i just kept staring at him
and i was i pulled her like who are
these people why are they here
this is our apartment we live here we
live and sleep yeah she was like oh
i didn't know i'm sorry yeah it's like
you didn't know you're sorry
i remember and i just kept staring at
this dude and he was feeling super
uncomfortable oh yeah
i was like i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy up
that's all i kept thinking about
he just kind of got it wow what did they
think this place was people
live here i was literally gonna [ __ ]
that guy up and i just kept staring at
him i think he was expecting me to say
hi to him
oh yeah dude so another story
was like because people kept thinking it
was like the headquarters everyone hangs
out there
um very few people knew that you can
actually
because this building's [ __ ] old like
built in 1920s
you can just lift the fire escape window
and get into my room yeah if the door's
locked
very few people knew that info this girl
she came around this and then and one of
our roommates
was getting busy oh my god
and they were being loud but she came in
anyway and she just
chilled in that dining room like office
table we had where we all did our work
we just sat there and waited until i
think i know who this is yeah i know who
this is
you know i've actually kicked that girl
out a couple of times like i'm so
[ __ ] pissed
because our place was okay it was a 4
000 square foot apartment it was huge
huge
right and i sometimes people would come
in i had no idea who the [ __ ] it was
and i would wake up and one time i saw
that girl she came out how did you get i
said who let you in who are you kicking
with things like
oh i'm just in town i'm just kicking it
i'm like get the [ __ ] out
how did you get in right she was getting
in through my [ __ ] window
there are times i come to my room and my
bed has a footprint on it
i'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're gonna sneak in take your [ __ ]
shoes off you know what the funny thing
was like
when when i saw her and this is what she
said to me she goes oh it's like well
you know khalif crashes here i was like
yeah because i
let him yeah we invite him he comes
through the front door
exactly he doesn't sneak in he calls me
to see when he's going to come in
and i let him crash her because he's
full sleeping in his [ __ ] car
overnight yeah
and so i let him crash on the couch on
the days that he has acting classes and
auditions
you know just to [ __ ] break into my
house and then suddenly expecting me to
be like
oh hey hey you're here like you know we
do that on friday nights
yeah this is like this week
you know we're chill like we're working
we're what the [ __ ] are you doing here
man i mean we kind of created this
really like fun environment where
everybody was allowed to come in
and dude there was sometimes dude we had
uh this one roommate where
i saw this dude he he used to hook up
with a lot of girls
yeah but he's going through a very dark
time and
because he used to go out with this girl
for a very long time the relationship
went bad and
until the story one day i'm gonna have
him on this podcast he's gonna hate that
i'm gonna bring this up
but that's why i'm not gonna say his
name which i never do but let me tell
you something
so this is when i first moved to k-town
right
and uh we were at this this uh club or
bar whatever
and our mutual friend was there with his
girl or whatever whatnot right yeah
and then he just recently got dumped by
his
long-term relationship i think they were
actually even engaged yeah at this point
they were together she's actually
a church friend of mine that he was
engaged to right so i've known her for a
very long time she's a very sweet girl
so we're at we're outside we're at this
place right it's a lounge slash club
we're drinking up it's getting smashed
or whatever right
this dude is so [ __ ] drunk at the
table he starts
he gets his alcoholic drink whatever it
is it was like a shot of like i don't
know some kind of clear
clear alcohol just throws it in my face
what
he goes throws it in my face and i'm
sitting there
and i'm getting mad and remember i just
have a very short temper and so i looked
at him i was like
you throw that [ __ ] drink in my face
one more time i'ma drag you outside beat
your [ __ ] ass that's what i literally
said to him
and he's drunk and i see him smiling
just
filling it up he's when he's drunk too
remember he said that glaze looked in
his eyes where it was just
like the lights are on nobody's home
yeah
[Laughter]
he's about to toss it in my face i
[ __ ] grab his hand and i'm like i
just told you i'ma beat your [ __ ] ass
oh my god i literally took the drink
that was like hold on i grab him by his
shirt
i drag him outside and i shove him
against the wall and i'm like yo what
the [ __ ] is your problem
he looks at me he goes she broke my
heart
and she starts crying because she broke
my heart
dude but you know i'm not surprised
you know what i'm not surprised so we
talked this about this on the my sassy
girl podcast
my sassy girl right the girl who [ __ ]
punched me in the face and
[ __ ] you met her yes
yeah she came over and we were
already out and we we came back to the
apartment and you were just
chilling and we were at the kitchen
window having a smoke
and you walked in get to the fridge
and she goes hey hey you're the comedian
right you're funny and you're like yeah
nice to meet you
yeah she goes tell me a joke say
something funny
i did my [ __ ] face like uh
she goes hold on hold on i have a joke i
have a joke why did the
copy and the dracula no way way
[Laughter]
she was trying to tell that she was
trying to and i remember what i said to
her too i was like what do you do for a
living and she was like i'm a teacher i
said why don't you shut the [ __ ] up and
teach me something
you were like okay and then you grabbed
her away i looked so
i was like because i don't know who she
was just coming at me and i'm like
so this podcast is brought to you by
fiverr if you are looking for a network
of on-demand freelance talent look no
further
whether you're launching your first
business scaling your current business
or need of extra support from graphic
design
copywriting marketing film editing
everything you need under the sun you
name it you can find the best help you
need on
fiber listen i have used fiber whenever
i needed a quick logo
a graphic done and fiber always had my
back it's super easy to contact
freelance work and get precise deadlines
from reliable help
because you don't need to stress out
whether you're going to get something or
not you don't need to do everything
yourself
that stupid stop wasting your time
trying to fill every role when you can
hire freelancers who can get it done for
you while you focus on the stuff you
need to get done
so check out fiverr.com and receive 10
off your first order by using my code
geniusbrain find all the digital
services you need in one place at
f i v e r dot com code geniusbrain again
that's
fiverr.com code brain
after that i had that whole incident in
washington where she punched me in the
face yeah and i came back
here and you didn't you didn't know what
happened but i was chilling in the car
and you were like yo what's up
yeah you've been like down or whatever
and i was like
yo this girl this and that and and
whatever and before i could even get to
the part where she punched my face you
were like yo
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like stop being a
get over that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
because i hated it
i was just like yeah i probably
shouldn't have david for advice
no you were right though i i had to
[ __ ] let that [ __ ]
i just had no tack back in the day
literally yo
david that you know now that could talk
through his thoughts it took time to get
this point
like i was i had zero attack yeah
it was like i know how to fix this but
you know it too
you didn't even need to know that she
[ __ ] punched me in the face
lied about like a [ __ ] abortion and
all this [ __ ] you're just like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out of
here
i don't [ __ ] like this girl
that's so [ __ ] funny dude so you
don't [ __ ] oh i almost said this no
you know this fool right so afterwards
afterwards
she broke my heart it starts crying
against this wall this will literally
lean against the brick wall and start
sliding down it
like a slug and so
me and our buddies we we go eat to that
at the the denny's in k-town yeah
afterwards trying to sober him up this
whole is so drunk
i [ __ ] you not he's drinking but he
doesn't know his mouth is still open
and so i see his water's going it is
coming out he's coming out
onto it oh my god just smashed out of
his mind
she hurt me this is no god weak flesh at
this point it's just
like i'm doing what i can exactly it's
just the saddest human being
ever dude sometimes too i kind of miss
being single because of these situations
like these
funny ass things that would happen it
was it's so ridiculous i can't make it
up but to be young in k-town though
yeah if we were still if i was still in
k-town now there would be so many more
stories but now i'm just
i'm kind of scared to go out late at
night you know what though
so i live in k-town now right and i
moved
there specifically because of a lot of
deep-seated things like about how i
never wanted to leave k-town after the
riots
right and i feel a lot of fulfillment
living there now right and paying my
rent and like being where i was born
but god damn it as the weeks go by i'm
like this place is
[ __ ] junk sometimes yeah sometimes
it's like i love it because
the culture and my family and all that
but like
the horn honking the traffic the [ __ ]
okay so one night i'm a little
insomniatic so
it's like 2 am chilling like watching
car model videos on youtube and i hear
[Music]
and the hunk the horn just going off
yeah not stopping and
you're like oh [ __ ] that was a big
accident right but i'm sitting there
and the horn is still going up huh
when you see movies what does that mean
that means that's just [ __ ] up like a
dead body
a head on the horn or some [ __ ] right so
i'm like i gotta see this
i put my jacket on yeah go outside i
gotta see this [ __ ]
and there's like this wrecked camry
right
and all four doors are open no
passengers
all the airbags are off and the front is
ripped off
right and the horn is just going off i
think the
front just got smashed really bad and
some guy walked up
open the hood and just unplugged the
battery turn off the horn
i'm like what the [ __ ] what happened
here and he goes go check out
just down the street three more cars
just smashed in
one of the wheels just under the engine
you know like this car just sideswiped
three
cars and then like [ __ ] stop and
whoever's in there
jumped out right this is outside of my
[ __ ] apartment
oh my god and i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
right and now there's crowds of people
from the neighborhood coming out seeing
it right and there was another
party at someone's apartment going on
right these trunk dudes came out and
they're like
i saw them i saw them they were like
teenagers right
and then there's a couple teenagers
there right
there they go and then they [ __ ] book
it
two of them two dudes boom down the
street and these drunk dudes chase
them hey you can't resort these drunk
justice dudes
that's hilarious chasing after these
guys running away right
and i'm checking out like holy [ __ ] and
then i see this bottle
this giant [ __ ] bottle like this big
right like a
like a co2 oxygen tank like when you go
scuba diving right
now what the [ __ ] is this and one of the
trunk guys come back
he's like man they're gone i couldn't
catch them right but then two [ __ ]
these other two girls
they're in the car too you can't run
don't [ __ ] run
and they're like uh like well no we
weren't
and then he's like this drunk guy is
just like captain of koreatown
i saw you i saw you like you guys jumped
out of the car
you guys grabbed the nos bottle and you
ran down the street the nas bottle was
too heavy so you dropped it
and they ran well you guys are really
good right
and he was like i saw you i saw you yeah
his memory was you saw the whole thing
what's wrong oh [ __ ] i started lecturing
these girls he was like
look you guys are getting high off
nitrous and driving your car
that's [ __ ] up he goes i'm drunk and
high right
now but i was at my house
i was saying this i'm like i don't know
if i love k-town or if i need to get out
of here
if you live in cape town you just have
the best stories dude because all this
crazy [ __ ] would happen happens
it just happens it's so fun what's the
funny thing is like this fool has
photographic memory about the accident
but i bet you where do you live i have
no clue
i have no idea where i am but i saw
everything dude it was well dude
all the all those like late night
karaoke nights were super [ __ ] fun
you know i had a random [ __ ] do you
remember i'm not sure if you remember
this because you were stupid drunk but i
think it was in chapman plaza
and then you got into an altercation
with somebody but you were so
[ __ ] drunk i remember you swung at
this guy
and you completely missed and you did a
full 360 spin and you fell on your ass
do you remember kidding me you no talk i
it was like in front of bullpup
this is you but i don't know what the
altercation was but
you're usually not the person provoking
somebody but this guy was being an
[ __ ] or something but
i remember because you were squaring up
on this dude
and i was like oh it's going to knock
this dude out it's going to fight this
guy right and you got
you're so drunk you're you're wobbling
you're like okay
i'm blacked out you're blacked out you
threw a full-on
swing at this fool right he didn't move
you missed him
and then you spun around and you fell on
the floor and the guy was like
but you were so drunk because i wasn't
there with you you were there earlier
either it was with like some seattle
friends or you were with somebody else
oh
[ __ ] i remember seeing you and then
there's some other your friends were
helping you up and i was like
i'm just going to pretend i didn't see
this cause if i go high
your friends were helping you up and i'm
like i'm just gonna save face for ed and
not say anything
can i tell you that's not the first time
that happened
that's why i believe you
[Laughter]
all right so at tigs right god damn it
ed
me dan and my brother at tiggs and
okay so there's just this homeless lady
like it's numb this lady is always
around um pioneer square and and tiggs
she's begging for money whatever and we
see her so much
it's almost like being a regular
customer
i don't know yeah you just give her
money and she'll go away
kind of thing and nobody she
it's just like it is what it is and
one day i hear well yeah where it takes
and this lady screaming the same lady we
know
help somebody help
and then i saw it was that homeless lady
i'm like what the [ __ ] who's [ __ ]
with her and this this
like dude just like walking up
at her and like getting pissed
and i was like damn we gotta go [ __ ]
this guy
up and then he goes all right
and i just ran by myself but they just
stayed and watched me
[ __ ] dead right and here's the thing
i'm blacked out because my brother and
you
told me this story and they said i
walked up and i was like hey man leave
her alone right
and dan was like at least he's being
honorable yeah
and then uh he was saying some [ __ ]
i honestly don't remember no but then
i was like leave her alone leave her
alone and then he shoved me
and i was like oh this is it and so i
grabbed him by the collar
and i threw a punch to shh like bring
him in and bring my fist to his face
i missed completely missed
and his chin like hit my wrist like it
scraped my wrist
and he was like all right all right man
and then he left
my brother was standing there like oh my
god
so embarrassed
dan was like what the [ __ ] are you
like yeah i guess you won
oh my god i don't know i don't know
what's worse that or that you're
watching you just in a distance i know
we're at the 7-eleven just watching you
dude just [ __ ] like not the 7-eleven
the [ __ ] uh
i wasn't at the 7-eleven but you could
see right in front of you
i'm like what the [ __ ] man i just was
like
how's what the [ __ ] is going on dude i'm
pretty sure there was a time when i was
looking for trouble
yeah just like [ __ ] it dude [ __ ] it
people would i mean it was pretty easy
to get in fight in k-town though like
there was always somebody starting [ __ ]
saying [ __ ] so i always just kind of
kept to myself dude even like
when i was way past that [ __ ] too and
looking at how dumb i was
you know um then now i'm older and i'm
still going to chapman to have dinner
with my family
this is before my sister moved to l.a
and she was wearing a seahawks jersey
um the 12 you know how they're the 12th
man and
so seahawks fans were 12. yeah well that
was the year
the seahawks played the patriots we know
what happened yeah yeah
and this we're just walking through
chapman this random [ __ ] k-town
boy he was a boy because he had pimples
he was like [ __ ] brady [ __ ] brighty at
my sister check the
guy all over again dude right yo [ __ ]
brady
and i'm like she's wearing a seahawks
because tom brady wears number 12.
oh my god and i was like she's wearing a
seahawks jersey dude
what's your problem and then he was like
oh
oh you you want some of this huh oh
you're talking [ __ ]
this guy was looking for a fight yeah
because i was like bro like
it's a [ __ ] seahawks jersey so
yeah you you run into that all the time
i mean thank god for the pandemic so we
don't have like
[ __ ] oc boys and valley boys coming
on the weekends and [ __ ]
trying to start i met with paul in
hawaii and we were going over old
stories too like k-town stories and he
brought the whole chipotle fight thing
right
in front of like near where he used to
live and then there was like
little things that i completely forgot
that i did
that he was telling me about that but he
was he was telling from his perspective
which i
which i only knew when i told him on
this podcast where
i was outside the chipotle and this guy
was just you know mouthing off i got so
[ __ ] mad
like when i get really angry i just i
start laughing for some reason
it's kind of menacing yeah it's kind of
cause i'm like crazy because the only
thing is like oh i'm gonna [ __ ]
murder this person yeah right
so we were outside of chipotle and i had
my hand on his shoulder i was
smiling and laughing and so paul thought
we were friends
right but literally i was telling that
if he doesn't sit the [ __ ] down i was
gonna murder this guy
i was so [ __ ] pissed but literally
paul was telling me that he was like
yeah and then when i
i didn't realize until later that you're
about to fight this dude afterwards i
was like yo what's up it was like but
you already threatened to kill this guy
and then you said you're gonna [ __ ]
beat his girlfriend's ass too for
[ __ ] mouthing off to you too
and the guys just walked up and left
because they were so scared but it was
just one of those
it's just always something was happening
in cape town dude if you like
want your life to be interesting and it
almost doesn't have anything or you can
be involved
yeah live in cape town you'll see
something something happen you'll see
some of the weirdest [ __ ] that happens
yeah what's the topic of this part yeah
so we're going to talk
so anyways this we go on
on weird diatribes but we actually want
to talk
we haven't done a [ __ ] movie podcast
right in a very long time
right but i do want to start this before
we go off so
we'll talk about tenant right and we
usually talk about a lot of korean films
or asian american films right but
i want to talk about tenant because i
didn't understand this film at all and i
watched it twice on a plane and it made
me mad
so i got really [ __ ] angry so um
i have been and this may seem like i'm
being a little pessimistic when it comes
to asian american films right
but i don't have anything against asian
american films i am an asian american
i'm looking for great films
minari was [ __ ] amazing i thought
that movie was really good
but when an asian american film isn't
good
i'm not going to say that it's good just
because i'm an asian american right and
you need to
hype it for the culture exactly
i think that our voice is being heard
now and that now we have to go and show
people that we have the chops to make
really great films we've seen that in
korean film we've seen in japanese film
we've seen it in chinese films
well now we have this genre of asian
american films that need to be created
that can be really great yeah
so i'm looking for great stuff right um
many people might disagree with me on
this i did not like raya
i thought raya was a [ __ ] big miss
and
also too i tried what listen i'm a big
fan of eddie huang
yeah i think eddie huang's vibe is dope
like he's when he speaks he's super
he's prolific at everything that he
talks about i watched boogie that was
one of the worst films
i'm sorry man like i [ __ ] with eddie
huang [ __ ] heavy
but there was so many bad things about
that writing it was
unreal and i expected and because eddie
huang i put him on a pedestal
i expected a lot better right right like
even it was just
terrible how corny it was
it's like was he holding on to fresh off
the boat
kind of stuff it's like holding on to
the very 90s
weird asian chokes and jokes right right
which is set in the 90s it's i don't
think it is i don't i i didn't get to
watch the whole film i watched like
about 10-15 minutes for your skip
through try to give it a chance
and i just hated it yeah it was just
hard to watch
there was just weird things that number
one just didn't make sense from
not just from a filmmaker's perspective
but from a viewer's perspective right
right
so for example just off the jump the the
humor and the writing was really bad
all right so there's this in the
beginning of the movie you have this
conversation with eddie
and uh the main character boogie
and like his uncle and they're kind of
setting up that he plays basketball and
the intro goes or whatever
the next thing you know he's in class
and this is there's the love interest
right
first of all the casting for the asian
guy he looked like he was 35. yeah he's
supposed to be in high school
yeah i think he's going to be in high
school and he's like 35 he looks like
he's 35 [ __ ] years old
yeah and there's this girl hot black
girl that he likes right he's like
staring at her but the way he stares at
it looks like he's about to roofie her
drink
you know that's what it looks like it's
it's very weird what a very weird
but the line off the jump was just
really corny
so she you know she's she comes to class
kind of late or whatever she says her
name and then she has an opinion about
something that's weird
and then he makes a comment to what
she's saying and the professor asks
what that dude's name is or the teacher
and he goes he goes
this is my name and he goes but my
stripper name is boogie that's the joke
and it's just all i heard in my in the
back of my head was wow
[Laughter]
exactly and then it skipped over to this
scene where
she's having this conversation with you
know boogie is in the gym and he's
staring at the two girls right
uh it's the girl that's his love
interest and a girl and his home girl
and they're talking about how like oh
yeah i probably i let him get it if he's
a
if he would if he stops staring at me so
weird and then her friend says this line
that just ripped my soul apart
she goes yeah i would admire sucking on
his you know sweet spare rib
sweet spirit like chinese food joke and
it's like
eddie man aren't you supposed to be like
the progressive
and i guess like maybe in his defense
these are probably jokes they hear when
he was a kid
right or whatever but it was so it
reminded me of
a bad 90s film right with like
bad 90s asian jokes right some kind of
like
20 20 joy luck club or 2021 choice
something
there's like an ode to like maybe how it
was in the past which you can do that by
the way the film looks but it doesn't
have to be like that in the dialogue
right you know what i mean and then
there was also charlotte i mean the god
that was in there and he was the the the
scout
and also like the casting for charlotte
i know i think charlemagne the god was
like an executive producer
right maybe that's why he had a role in
the film he did not fit that role
at all he's supposed to be like a scout
for the nba
or something like that right and so he
comes in or a college scout or something
comes in and charlemagne the god is how
charlemagne the god is and he's making
his jokes but he comes in
and you could tell when they're allowing
artistic freedom for an
actor to go ahead and just say whatever
they want yeah and charlemagne the god
is being charlemagne the god
and he's a he's a scout yeah all scout
has to do is say scout [ __ ]
yeah like his comedic relief made no
sense in the film
so before he walks into the house and
he's about to meet like boogie's parents
or whatever
he goes in and he goes yeah he goes he
goes oh do i take my shoes off he's like
yeah yeah i respect it i respect it
that's cool
and and he's just sitting here like oh
this place is real nice like saying all
this stupid random dialogue
like it's absolutely pointless like
would somebody like a scout nba scout
like coming in and out of your house
like do that it doesn't make sense
and it's like the humor was just there
just to be like
it's so apparent that it's trying to be
funny that it's not
you know yeah and i just i was so
disappointed that film boogie and that's
the kind of thing i look at
with asian american film where you're
like
you get mixed between the art of
filmmaking
and knowing how to make a film right
just down to its fundamentals
and copying what a movie is supposed to
be like
right and just copying and then trying
to make a cash cow thing out of it
or whatever and it's like man you made a
very expensive mistake then
yeah and you know eddie huang too to his
credit you know he's always
unapologetically himself which i really
do appreciate right
but that doesn't mean he's going to make
a good film is this based off of him
could be i don't know older fresh off
the boat it's if
like eddie from this tv show got older
well yeah and then
also too the reason why i was
disappointed was because he was very
adamant
about how much executives
ruined fresh off the boat and his
personal story so i'm like oh he gets to
shine and see what he's gonna do and i'm
like bro you're
yeah your [ __ ] movie was just as
corny as fresh off the boat what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
you had the executive control and
it didn't turn out any better making a
film is really hard like i said i'm not
knocking on
his uh what he did which is amazing you
know he made a film it's dope
but making a film is it's
really difficult i don't think people
understand how hard it is yeah and
people sometimes say to me why don't you
direct your own film oh yeah right
jackass
how the [ __ ] would i direct my own film
it's not that easy
like do you have like six figures just
to start
yeah yeah also too people don't
understand there's a reason why a lot of
these youtubers who make their own film
it's terrible because they grossly
undermine or under value or appreciate
the value of what a good director does
yeah
it's like oh that movie used the red
camera
we got a red camera too that [ __ ]
doesn't matter
camera doesn't mean yeah [ __ ] i keep
telling people this right
the skill set that's involved to create
a film is way beyond just the equipment
being used yeah the equipment is the
bonus
that's that's exactly what it is
everybody keeps asking me i tweeted this
[ __ ] out too and i i wanted people to
understand the [ __ ] for real because
everybody asks yo i'm getting in the
film what should i get uh should i get
like a
sony a7s3 or should i just go ahead and
get like a like like a red scar like a
used one
and i always write back and i wrote back
you suck
it doesn't matter what you [ __ ] buy
it's still going to suck
it doesn't [ __ ] matter right and they
don't understand that they think
that if they buy better equipment that
their film is going to be better
no you're going to make a 15 000 regret
exactly like because you actually just
because you bought a nicer camera
means that you can control it better
than a dslr
dslrs are way easier to use than film
cameras yeah
lighting matters in these in these film
cameras right because lighting is
everything these are controlled
scenarios
like i started school before
like hd was a standard like we were
working in standard def
and all of these things and then
learning hd as it came into the freight
in the middle
of my school year and all this [ __ ] you
know
like and that's what i learned between
using hd and
the standard of cameras i'd go
get to check out uh one of the hd
cameras right
but because i didn't know how to
manipulate light well because i wasn't
learning how to
composite my shots it still looked like
[ __ ] just in higher resolution
yeah it's just got you got a 4k shitty
image sometimes if just because you have
a nice camera this
like if you can't light it if you can't
set it up
everything yeah it's literally
everything
everything
and people here and i'm around a lot of
some like some of these young creators
where they talk about camera specs it's
like i don't give a [ __ ] about your
camera respect your videos are trash
you don't know how to use any of this
stuff yeah like that's the problem
dude uh 28 days later later they shot
that on an xl1
canon tv camera that's [ __ ] crazy
they shot that sd it's a standard def
movie yeah they shot it on tv
and you know what cult classic great
made millions of
all that [ __ ] didn't matter what [ __ ]
camera they used exactly they use that
camera because it looks like
handheld like home footage and they and
they were like they wanted it to look
like
if they made a movie in the apocalypse
yeah they wouldn't have access to
these yeah really expense cameras right
that's the idea
that even when people choose their
cameras there's an art behind it too
yeah yeah and i think that's like the
biggest fallacy with this new generation
of creators and filmmakers they think
that you need
bigger better stuff rather than learning
how to work on the craft
this isn't just old head talk this is
legit how film and creating works
like they go cool i made three minute
sketches guess what next step
full feature wow yeah you wanna know how
to break it down between seven
acts now yeah what the [ __ ] are you
talking about it doesn't work that way
there's a reason why you see a lot of
youtubers who do
films they're hot trash minus me and
[ __ ]
but the reason why is because i wasn't
directing that yeah i wasn't
it was justin and justin is the guy
who's a seasoned actor who's
been around film people his whole life
that [ __ ] watches like
10 12 films a week right just because he
loves that craft that much and that's
the dedication that it takes for you to
become a great storyteller
and that's what film is and so you see
all the stuff where
they have this is what a lot of people
do because i used to do this a lot too
where
there's like a joke or an idea and they
focus on the joke and the idea rather
than the whole story
and so you see these random sporadic
moments in these films
where they're like oh i i remember this
time when i was a kid if somebody said
this joke i'ma put it in
what this film is the film about yeah
[ __ ] your joke
so that's the problem with a lot of
these modern movies though
they set it up okay so it's perfect
example the fast and furious series
right so yeah
look when justin lin came in and fast
furious part four
five six those were oh he did tokyo
drift too yeah
he rebooted that [ __ ] to a place where
it's gonna make money like those were
the best fast movies
yeah was tokyo drift four five and six
and
and he left after part six and seven was
hot trash
eight is trash two and you can see it
where it's like
um like before they write a script
they're like oh we should have cars
parachute out of a plane we should have
yeah we should have a car go through
three buildings and survive
uh we should have a race towards and
through downtown l.a and there's a
missile helicopter of chasing them or
some [ __ ] right
they make the ideas then they write the
script behind it
the story to do the stunts fast and
furious has literally become the
best comedy i've ever seen it's one of
the funniest [ __ ] films i've ever
seen but that's why i'm excited about
fast nine because justin lin's coming
back
dude it's it literally fast and furious
became
a it was a movie about misfits that
drive cars
yes now it is basically the marvel
superhero film yeah they're like double
of seven ages all of them they can't die
you know and it's like in their
contracts it's written so they can't
actually lose a fight either
get the [ __ ] out have you noticed though
they never lose fights
since fast five nobody actually loses a
fight
it has to either be a draw right or they
don't lose
dude there was one scene in the fast and
furious series that cracked me the [ __ ]
up man
all right it was it was it was they were
on a bridge and there was
tanks yeah which which movie was this
that was fast
six but dom toretto flies to like
another oh yeah right oh yeah and when
he got up it was the cleanest t-shirt
i've ever seen
it was so if you look at the film the
lines on the shirt that was just brandly
open
is still on him yeah just the physics of
how fast the tank is going in the force
it's going at then it gets stopped at a
complete stop
then he flies in the air catches letty
through the air
and a windshield stops him
but that's the beauty of it when you
embrace that not a single scratch
yeah and his t-shirt unscathed
yeah the most the nicest shirt i've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life
i promise you guys like something about
it like maybe i i
i watch every film in theaters yeah me
too just to let you know
i i just have a thing for justin lin i
think i i think he does make good films
especially with the fast series i'm just
i'm just ready for it because i think he
does know how to make films
like very very even though it's hammy
right it's [ __ ] corn
right yeah but in his head it's still
this happened therefore
this in the story and because of this
this happened therefore this dude later
fast
in other words it's just [ __ ] stun
stun sunset and like
vin diesel's voice is almost inaudible
it's so deep i don't know what the [ __ ]
he's saying he's just growling
throughout the whole film now
that's probably part of the shtick now
it's like probably his own arnold
right it's like yeah it's okay if you
don't understand him just like arnold
that's your thing he's like all right
yeah
it's about family it's always about
family
you know i forgot my family i remember
out there about my father
yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] is this guy
saying dude
dude have you bro i went on a whole
binge yesterday
of watching tyrese lose his mind yeah
what the [ __ ] was that like
i think it started with the rock the
rock [ __ ] with him when his album
released
oh wait it was when uh wait i
he got upset at the rock because he was
doing his own spin-off versus doing
another fast yeah
furious yeah and in the middle of
filming that tyrus released an album
right
and the rock made a video on social
media i remember this
he was like hey guys uh i just i was on
my plane
and i'm here to film my new movie right
and he's just like and he's wearing a
suit and everything he looks super sharp
and i heard my boy tyrese came out with
a new album right
all right so i listened to it on the
plane right and he's like well you know
what i think
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] hard
hot garbage it's [ __ ] disgusting and
you threw it out like you always [ __ ]
tyrese like he [ __ ] around with kevin
hart like that too yeah
yeah but he was serious oh for real he
was angry
he was serious rock like [ __ ] tires [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this sounds
sounds like [ __ ] doesn't it hey right
everybody here you all heard it right
sounds like [ __ ] right
yeah [ __ ] oh for real yeah he [ __ ]
made that you could see it
like he was serious he was serious and i
think that started tyrus's [ __ ] down
like mental
downward spiral why the rock is like
rising
i had no [ __ ] idea yeah that's pretty
sure where it started
i thought it was because he because of
the fact that he started a new film and
then
obviously tyreese is like he's messing
with my money my family's money
exactly and then he went through the
whole custody issue with his daughter
and they did that [ __ ] animaniacs
joke about him
did you see this animaniac oh my god
hold on a second i have to show you this
so there was this trend
where they started kind of melodyning
the voice of people to match
the animations totally insane i'm gonna
type in right now animaniacs tyrese and
it's the
funniest [ __ ] you'll ever hear it's kind
of sad because tyrese is losing his mind
but he's acting like a crazy
person because he's crying to you know
talking about his his daughter that he
might lose
and how much he misses her because he
hasn't seen her in a while okay and so
he's crying in this video but somebody
took an
audio snippet and put it into the
animaniacs track and it blew the [ __ ]
up dude
oh no no the internet
never loses my baby
bro i never left cigar on the video
pete the internet is so [ __ ] up but he
was losing his mind dude
did you see how he was trying to promote
his album his last album
no no ed it's the worst it's just sad
right
this dude got so much [ __ ] if you
okay let's start with this
this girl's got so much flack from a
bunch of publications and people in the
comments right
so his thing is that he is like the
voice of r b
because he does real r b and he does
he's a great r b singer i love
all of his [ __ ] og tracks right right
he also start started a group with uh
with tank and genuine called tgt
which is really dope but they only did
one album and [ __ ]
he decides to do a post where there is a
lady
that is sleeping in a bush on a lam an
older woman
like a grandma and he makes this post
like a very serious person
you see this there's people out here
sleeping on r b
like can you believe her oh my god and
this lady is sleeping with her mouth
open
and he uses her as an example so what it
turns out that lady's [ __ ] homeless
of course
and he's like they're sleeping on r b
and he's making this joke
about the homeless lady what the [ __ ]
are you doing and people are like
what made you think that was a good idea
why the [ __ ] would you do that
and so he go he makes a video and he
goes back to that spot
to explain himself and the explanation
is not anymore
he goes i'm just trying to put out a
point that people are sleeping on
r b and that's why i recorded this woman
it's like
it still doesn't make it okay and he
goes i didn't know she was homeless
still not okay still his album flopped
right yeah of course
and he was losing a lot of money right i
remember this story somehow this is when
i was all over the news and [ __ ] about
this
you know who saved him who will and jada
pinkett smith
oh really yeah they because he was also
made a post by how he's going broke now
because his alpha flopped and everything
[Music]
all that [ __ ] right so they gave him
five million dollar loan
get back on his feet and they said get
off social media
until the fast and furious [ __ ] yes
until fast now when he gets to check
back he could pay him back
yeah you know what's even crazier about
that [ __ ] though it's like
he he didn't do a good job because he
was on social media and let me tell you
this
i will show you this video later and
i'll put it in this in this video
i'll just explain it to you so tyrese
he's like on this
philanthropic vibe right where he sees
this homeless guy he's a very handsome
dude green eyes he looks like he could
be some surfer dude but he's homeless
and he goes
i'm over here i'm over here on melrose
and whatever in beverly hills or
whatever
and i see this billboard you see that
billboard i used to model a lot i was a
model
i used to be on those billboards this is
a homeless guy right here
and this guy is handsome he's a handsome
man no you know pause whatever
and i just need i'm i'm a man i've been
blessed with social media by god
and i'm going to change this man's life
listen and he comes up to him and he
talks to him he goes hey man he's like
yeah i'm homeless i'm on the streets but
you know i was a drug addict and then i
got myself cleaned up and now it's
really hard for me to get a job he goes
cool cool cool
well i am blessed with social media
friends so anybody out there
that can help this man
when he is somebody who can [ __ ] help
him
and he's on instagram live saying can
somebody help this man please he goes
hold on i got something for you
he walks over to his car opens up his
car his suv is escalated or whatever
right
looks into his bag he digs into it right
i'm like damn he's about to give him
some money
he pulls out his album
he pulls out his album and gives it to
him
when this guy is broke and he needs
money he goes god bless he goes hey you
got you got he goes i have a cd player
he goes
good man he's like good hey man that's
tight you got a cd player here let me
let me gift you with this album of mine
he goes number one album in multiple
countries
he goes here this is my gift to you
instead of
countries excluding america
he gives his homeless he's so he's using
this as a
as a as a launching point to promote his
album
dude he's like i [ __ ] up last time how
do i help homeless people
that's really the move that he's doing
dude he's he's so
disconnected from reality yeah and this
guy looks like what the [ __ ] just give
me some
money bro i'm broke he gives him his
album his failed album
and then you look in his instagram this
is where it gets worse
it's just it's videos of of him in the
subway system in new york
just talk he goes hello everybody my
name is tyrese
i'm an independent artist i this is my
first independent album without a label
and this is my album that is debuting
and the video ends that's it
you're not hey it has no point you're
not gonna like sing in the subway you're
not gonna like
nothing and then you can see people are
completely disinterested
completely disinterested and he posts
the next video
where it's him just recording his face
he sits down and he turns the camera
over to a lady and she goes hey
you tyrese right and he looks back his
face looks pissed and video ends
he's lost his [ __ ] mind dude these
are like basic social media
like like
he filmed a homeless person to
sleeping as a point as a launching point
to say
people are sleeping on my music like bro
what are you
thinking you [ __ ] maniac
man well i am speechless like this
i love this fool's music i mean is it
any more different than when
you say like remember that girl who like
faked like she was drilling in some
[ __ ] plates
for like one the wall yeah that kind of
the blm thing yeah
good luck
mercedes yeah i mean like isn't it just
another version of that
where it is just this no matter what
class you're in
these people are just disconnected from
realities they get just
lost in social media or they're quote
unquote fame
it's just what's wrong with him i don't
know but he definitely needs help man
yeah like the whole crying in front i
mean shout out to the person who made
the animaniacs
that is hilarious i didn't mean my baby
can you can you can you fathom how rich
will and jada pinkett smith are to the
point where they could just give away 5
million on a loan
i dream i dream of having money just to
give away
yeah you know you can give five million
like it's nothing
it's like five million whatever just
stay off social media
yeah you can't do that yeah and he
literally can't do it he was like
thank you i appreciate you jada will you
the best wish i don't even think he
should have released that information
like that
i'm pretty sure jaden and jada piggy
smith and will smith did not appreciate
that
when they told you to get off social
media yeah because hey
here's five million it's a loan all you
have to do is not be on social media the
next day
jada and will thank you so much for
giving me this 5 million
he's a [ __ ] weirdo dude he was the
one
that released the information that dr
dre
um had that apple deal but they were
buying beats and it was going to make
them a billionaire
right what the [ __ ] he got on instagram
like
yeah we're doing it we're like we
we doing it we yeah and like like hyping
up
like apple buying um beats by trey and
dr tray becoming a billionaire
he was quite pissed and drake got pissed
and even snoop dogg there's a part in
that dock
i think it's on apple uh plus yeah that
[ __ ] they're
they're just about that tyrese that
stupid [ __ ]
and even tycho is like just him just uh
just shaking his head dude there was
almost cost him a billion dollars
he's so [ __ ] stupid yeah why would he
do that
just oh here's another thing i remember
he lost like some fifty thousand dollar
chain jet skiing
during mtv spring break oh my gosh so
he's been a problem for a long time
for a long time tyrese is [ __ ] nuts
man that's
so crazy isn't it weird how i how do i
know this story i don't follow this just
he just shows up on the news for
something he just said
weird antics yeah and dr dre recently
just went through that crazy divorce
like for 800 million dollars that's all
his apple money
yeah it's it's something ridiculous but
then all these stories about dr dre
being like an abusive husband like
beating his wife everything's starting
to come up
and they they took that part of the
movie right
they skipped the part where he beat up
that mtv vj dude yeah
oh man they sk they they made that scene
where he was driving because he was
pissed in his ferrari because easy got
aids and he was dying
yeah he was pissed right he was dui
drunk and driving [ __ ] around in
reality
people don't know about these
celebrities man like i keep telling you
man just because
i don't know why people assume that
human beings on a public platform are
really good people
how come they get the benefit of the
doubt of being a good human being
because we like stories
we need protagonists
and we need antagonists but there is a
sense
of people specifically marketing
specifically
obviously i mean we're going to talk
about movies
um we have this in tendency as humans
even in our personal lives to make
ourselves a hero
right yeah this is dr dre's movie of
course
of course dr dre yeah this [ __ ] oh
i mean it's one of those things like
we're not going to make us
ourselves the antagonist yeah but if you
can just step
out of that and stop telling stories but
tell them objectively as they are i can
tell you about the time i tried to [ __ ]
someone up and totally failed
you know yeah and you know what that i
would make that part of my life story
and it would be a comedic story but in
straight out of compton
maybe it's not so funny to be a woman
right
yeah like it's not something you really
whatever and there's not a real
character arc for him there
or whatever and i could see if you had
the control or some [ __ ] like that
he's not going to want that [ __ ] out
yeah
he just when i see people have a very
odd perception of themselves too where
i i even think to the point where people
they don't think that they have flaws
oh my gosh like people suck their own
dick so hard
yeah especially when some people show me
their music or there's like some kind of
video that they're doing
and they expect a certain reaction
because they think it's the most amazing
thing on earth yeah which makes me
wonder it's like who
who is in your circle it goes back to
tyrese who the [ __ ] is in tyrese's
circle
okay so i'm gonna tell you this story
you know this guy named sammock
right yeah chubby christian artist
right my sister is a big fan of his
and i listen to his music because of the
mutual friends we work through
yeah you know guess what he ended up at
fishbowl one day he was just chilling
there i was like oh [ __ ]
right mutual friends in production
whoever doesn't that girl who used to
break into apartment yeah i guess you
know
and um i was like yo what's up dude like
i've
been listening to music a long time my
sister's a huge fan
shook his hand and goes i know you
you're at park
i was like oh [ __ ] like how do you know
me
right and he goes you told this girl her
music video
sucked and she quit video because of you
and i was like uh
and he just looked away and i was like
and i stepped back like
the [ __ ] was that all about like i just
met you dude yeah
right and i was thinking so hard what
the who the [ __ ] is he talking about and
this guy's from the east coast right
yeah
and i remembered i remembered [ __ ]
10 years ago right
i got this dm from a girl because i was
making these videos
um and she saw my [ __ ]
and she sent me a dm like hey i'm making
a music video
what do you think of this and honestly
it was terrible yeah
it was um i just
i didn't say it sucks don't put it or
whatever i said
um you shot this in the dark and you
have no lights
and you shot it with tv camera that's
not good with low lights
and i said you can't re-edit this or
color it
because there's no light information you
gotta shoot it again
you need lights that's what i remember
apparently i made her [ __ ] quit
okay her her career let's just talk
about this for a second
number one don't ask people to critique
your stuff expecting praise
right you already [ __ ] up that means
you're already sucking your own dick
with this girl
she's already [ __ ] sucking your own
[ __ ] like you're
you expected i haven't heard it that way
yeah she's over here just [ __ ]
sucking your own [ __ ]
so she asked you for critique i don't
know who this girl
is you don't know who she is and what
she expected you was to
validate what she wanted to hear number
one lady you already [ __ ] up
number three number two or number three
whatever
number 17. here's the other problem with
that right yeah
and this is the the the big issue with
that as well
if some random person telling you that
you did something wrong in your video
broke your spirit to make me a video
that means you suck you are a brittle
brittle human being yeah you weren't
meant to do this in the first place
exactly if it took a random human being
to say that hey you have made a few
mistakes on this is what you should redo
was the reason why you quit
you are making excuses you blamed it on
a random person because you knew that
you didn't have the skills to do it
none that i'd meet this guy who i
appreciate for his
his art and his music and he
automatically thinks i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] as soon as he saw me
that's probably because he liked the
girl or something
yeah that makes sense 100 100 that means
he liked that girl
no nobody would ever defend somebody
that hard out of nowhere to be his
a [ __ ] knight in shining armor unless
he liked that girl yeah or it was
somebody really really important to him
right because right now i guarantee he
went back and he told that girl that
story hey i stood up for you and i told
that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dude sam [ __ ] you dude
like she should have just went to him
it's like hey brother let me show you
the dm i said i critiqued her video
and if she quit because of this it's
because she
sucks she sucked then dude it is what it
is yeah what were you expecting to hear
and i had like forgotten about that [ __ ]
it was like and it was just
i only remember because it was so
[ __ ] random yeah and then i put two
and together they're both from virginia
and i was like oh
like that's [ __ ] this is the dumbest
[ __ ] i've ever but that's so weird
though this is like
well because i know him too right he's
like super nice to me right
but i'm trying to understand in that
situation just like what were you gonna
do
were you gonna fight him yeah why would
you do that that's
and that's another thing where i stand
at too if you want to talk to me bro
like i don't think nicely of you i think
you're a piece of [ __ ]
and if i see you i'll [ __ ] you up this
time too you know
that's so random i'll probably miss my
punch
it's like hey hey let me tell you i
don't care about threatening to beat you
up
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] you anyway [ __ ] hey let me
tell you something the next time i see
you i'm gonna miss my first punch
but the second one you better watch the
[ __ ] watches [ __ ]
christian singer yeah well that's the
well
i wonder why he did that he doesn't i
don't know he's like five foot
three maybe he's like why would you do
that i mean hey i was also a chubby dude
at that time
maybe he's also fat too though yeah
maybe we were both unassuming he thought
he was better than me
i'm so funny both he was like you fat
butt yeah oh he's fatter than me [ __ ]
you
both of you guys are fat as [ __ ] look at
each other i'm gonna beat this fat ass
you're like i'm gonna beat this fat ass
i'll [ __ ] you up fat boy he can't be
slower than me
dude fat boys resenting each other
that's so weird that's so weird that he
would do that it was it was completely
weird
i know honestly here's the thing um did
you see
louis ck came up came out with a new
stand-up oh really
on his website because he can distribute
himself right yeah make all that money i
didn't see it yet but a clip of it
put out came out and he just talks about
his [ __ ]
right and it comes down to your kinks
right your sexual kinks
and he's like you know your kink is your
king don't tell anyone about it
and then he was like you know even if
you ask them
right and they say yes don't even do it
yeah yeah and i was thinking about like
this girl asked me what i
thought about her work you know
and because i gave my honest opinion she
quit
he asked this girl if you could like do
something infinitely
crazy and weird and it made her quit
mm-hmm and i think like i was like
why are you doing this then if you
oh okay wait that was [ __ ] up i know
what you do different
i know what you mean i'm not like i
didn't sexually harass this girl but it
was it was one of those things like
like well you're kind of being asking
for this girl it's like you
why are you asking me to critique your
video and i critique it and then you're
like what the [ __ ]
i'm a stranger and you expected a
stranger to lie to you and say it was
good
yeah what was the point of that yeah
also too when you're in a creative space
you need people to critique your work
who are better than you
at what you do that's how you get better
there's you
why would you ask i mean that doesn't
make any sense to me
if let's say if i'm if i want to go into
acting again right like i'm a full-time
actor
and then i do this audition tape and i
send it to justin who i
highly respect yeah and justin goes dude
this [ __ ] is terrible
like what the [ __ ] were you doing with
this line you didn't emote here like
your your body manners are really
awkward you look very weird yeah i'm not
gonna go to my room be like
you know i'm quitting i'm quitting
because of justin chan yeah i'd be like
cool this is somebody i respect and
admire i gotta change the stuff or this
or this tape is gonna be terrible
he knows what he's talking about and
that's what's kind of weird because i i
maybe i thought about this too much
because
this girl had it in mind to remember
that and then tell another influencer
about that in hopes that this guy will
one day meet me and this guy
in his head said one day if i meet ed
park i'm gonna tell him what's up
and [ __ ] years later we actually mean
and that's the first thing he tells me
i'm like bro you're a [ __ ] weirdo
what was he what was he doing at
fishbowl he was just chilling i don't
know he was there
and oh he's worked with uh clara before
probably
i don't know but it was just like that
was the weirdest [ __ ] introduction
i've ever had was like what were you
gonna do man
what was like yeah like also if you're a
nice guy just be a [ __ ] nice guy man
that's all i said oh dude i i've heard
of you've heard your music my
sister's a huge fan i know you you made
someone quit their career
look that's not like fighting words yeah
like what am i supposed to do and then
you just looked away like
uh and ignored me that's so weird
but it's also you know you're in the
studio of my best friend right
like what are you doing here i don't
know how odd like
sometimes i wonder what goes on in
people's heads when they do that it's
because it's so easy just to say words
without
self-righteousness maybe it could be the
christian
they did the right thing yeah it could
be that christian
knight in shining armor type of [ __ ]
dude yeah it's like it could be the oppa
thing i still i stood up for
azeropa and now i'm i'm i'm the good guy
yeah i remember that remember when you
told me that [ __ ] seven years ago
oh yeah i finally saw him yeah that's
weird i just don't understand what the
end result
is right so for example let's and i've
told multiple stories too where you know
i have trouble controlling my mouth
but i have a point in what i say and
i'll continue this conversation with
that person right so somebody says
something really weird to me or they
kind of
break up the mood i look at them and i
go why why'd you do that what are you
doing
and the reason why i address that is
because i'm trying to get them to stop
doing that so we can continue a good
conversation yeah
that's the point so for in his case when
he confronted you was like you're the
guy that did that
what next are you gonna say let's take
it outside
are you gonna tell me to call her and
apologize
what was the point what and he just said
what he said and then he goes
oh [ __ ] let me look off
let me let me look off into this that's
what happened yeah and this is like it
looks off to the distance and starts
opening up a book backwards
so it's really what were you gonna do
man
like what's that what's the end game and
i was caught by surprise too like
because i'm not the
like let's [ __ ] go like i had to
think about what the [ __ ] this guy
talking about
yeah yeah like he knows me because of
that and
i had to think through it was like oh my
god that girl
because of this stupid thing yeah
[ __ ]
not using lights and that's the reason
why
lights that's what i said use you need
lights
absorb light that's what they're for and
also
and so it goes back to the whole thing
where you know when people talk about
really good cameras and stuff yeah they
don't know how cameras work
and they're also the dslr is kind of
what
it did a lot of great things in allowing
uh low budget films to be made
but then people now assume that these
film cameras work like dslrs and it's
not
that case dslrs are full-frame cameras
the sensors are
way [ __ ] bigger and they're made to
absorb a lot more light
because number one they were photo
cameras first and then they were film
cameras yeah
all that codec the coloring all that is
already pre-described
yeah right it's in there you don't
really have to do much right that's why
people like canon colors
people tend to dislike sony colors but
they fixed a lot of those issues lately
yeah but they don't understand for
example too they didn't understand
but when people bought uh reds right
yeah they're like oh my god anything
past iso
800 which is really high or iso 600 is
super grainy
what the [ __ ] like my dslr i'll push it
to iso 2000
or whatever shutter angle whatever the
shutter angle is right yeah and it's
perfectly fine i was like yeah because
you're working with the dslr
it's made for people to do [ __ ] on the
run and gun so you don't have to think
about much
and they kind of base it off the a7s
platforms right whereas a 12 megapixel
sensor which each [ __ ] megapixel was
made to absorb a [ __ ] ton of light
right and so when you are out when
you're doing these travel vlogs and
you're doing these really
these shots that you need to get in
really tight spaces in the middle of the
night
that's what it's for so they'll like
copy and paste their color correction
for their cam
like canon mp4s and then like
throw it onto their red footage and it
looks like [ __ ] like yeah like
yo raw footage is different 100 yeah and
they'll just buy like just because it's
an expensive camera
yeah it's just a lot of the stuff
they're p they're expecting shortcuts
and they don't understand that
it's just a different thing you have to
know how to shoot things
lighting is so [ __ ] important
lighting is the hardest thing dude like
even i
still don't understand until this day i
just know when i like a shot but i don't
know how to mold the light in the scene
i'm such a novice like i only do like
three-point lighting
yeah um and where's my key light fill
light headlight
specifically yeah and that's where i
have to look at my [ __ ] too and just be
like i'm not a dp
you know and i can accept that i can
keep learning more but then am i
catching up with the newest tag
the newest accessories and all that [ __ ]
not really
you know like i just need to know what i
need the resolution i need
and whatever thank god for art school
obviously
like through the school like if you have
one camera you kind of know
every camera how it works like the way
they taught me through so
at least that but so what i'm seeing is
people just picking up the cheapest red
they can
through all this investment and credit
and they put themselves in a hole and
they don't exactly know how to work dude
there was this one kid this dude sucked
so bad and i'mma say his name yeah i did
not like this kid at all his kid was
named
do you remember this kid
[Music]
do you remember your [ __ ] do you
remember this trash yes
so this little kid he's also a little
his father's also a pastor
okay he's only one of those little
christian kids this little [ __ ]
man is such a [ __ ] trash bag he
number one he he just he was one of
those kids that
talks so much [ __ ] about how dope he was
yeah and how much he knew
and how everyone else sucked out every
and his work was
the worst it was like the worst like
beginning intro to film making [ __ ]
you've ever seen
and by the way when he bought his red at
the time which was the red i think it
was a red one yeah it was a red scarlet
it was the one that dan got yeah
this kid maybe shot one or two videos
and his dad bought him a red scarlet and
he was walking around like yo i could
he wanted to be the next big like movie
exactly
it was the most unhumble piece of [ __ ]
i've ever met in my life and his work
[ __ ] sucked this kid i
met him through that uh
uh water for life uh fundraising concert
we had
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so we then
tony hun
all that [ __ ] we like like put some work
in through i was doing the
big video screen all that dan was doing
all the production all the putting all
this work into it
and then after it was done i see this
kid in the green room and backstage
i don't know how he got there or
whatever um
i just say what's up and he says what's
up that's that's the first time and
last time i've ever met him that was
[ __ ] 2012.
dude and then he asked me on facebook
so it's like all right i met you right
and
and then like just like you said this
guy would talk
so much [ __ ] about like even [ __ ] like
interstellar doesn't deserve any of his
oscars or any of that [ __ ] like he talks
so much [ __ ] about great artists
with nothing to show for it right but
when i would say something like
how i didn't enjoy breaking bad right
did you watch breaking bad
yes i enjoyed breaking bad the first two
or three seasons
right over time i didn't because it hit
close to home
yeah my dad being the walk i
sorely related to the [ __ ] kid yeah
the crutches
because of how he sees his dad in that
relationship right
i just didn't like the way how this
[ __ ]
walter white didn't see any consequences
didn't get
caught all this [ __ ] or whatever right
and the kind of [ __ ] i saw in my life
and the way they glorified meth in the
show
i didn't like that you know and i just
made mention of it
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] just gave
me so much [ __ ] for being a hack
a hack how are you a hack he's done
nothing
i don't know man and he just talks [ __ ]
and honestly i didn't reply
because i was like i don't even know
this [ __ ] this guy but it's been
in the back of my head and i never said
anything and then you brought him
up it's so funny you know what the funny
thing is is like he would never say that
to somebody in person he's
literally this this pale-faced emaciated
little [ __ ]
literally the tiniest pale-faced
emaciate
emaciated little dweeby-ass [ __ ] that
has the smallest voice but when he goes
online he talks a lot
of [ __ ] [ __ ] he talks so much [ __ ] about
people it's
unfucking real and he has nothing to
show for it
you could say whatever you want if your
work is
great and no matter he maybe he got
better i don't [ __ ] know
the weird hey man i'm still i like i
don't see anything
yeah i don't see nothing yeah because he
was supposed to be the next biggest
director it's how he would talk about
himself
this little [ __ ] 19 year old [ __ ] at
the time yeah i mean like and he cycled
through
like the youtube scene and just nobody
used him ever again yeah people just got
tired of his [ __ ]
you know and i think i don't know if he
needs some time to look through it but
like even kensin was like hey do you
want to go have dinner with him i said
[ __ ] no why is kenzon hanging out with
him because he was like hey man he's a
changed guy and this and that
and for me i was like come on man i'm
korean like
[ __ ] that guy yeah i'm like my reason
it was a few years back i was like my
resentment's right high
i'm not gonna see that [ __ ] well
i mean the best way for that kid to make
amends with people is for him to
apologize
because the way that he was carrying
himself and the type of [ __ ] that he
would talk to and he would talk about it
to my personal
talk about my personal friends just
because he wanted to be a part of
something so he would hop on a bad wagon
and talk [ __ ]
is how that kid was he is the clear
example of everything
that is wrong with the with the social
media generation yeah right
all talk online when you come up to this
kid's face he crumbles he's quiet
he doesn't say she hasn't seen any of
his work because he's not good yeah
and that's the thing too and then he
could sit there and critique what other
people do when he has nothing to show
for his own personal work
he also was the kid where his mommy and
daddy bought him everything
they bought him a 20 000 [ __ ] dollar
camera before he could even show what he
was worth he didn't even know how to use
the camera
yeah on top of that he wanted to be a
director he sold it later too
just a few years later of course
hilarious yeah you know i mean it was
just the weird thing of how this guy
wouldn't leave me alone like and i had a
dmm like bro
i don't [ __ ] know you because like i
even had to say like
i said it out loud too in a post just
being like the korean church
um they don't shriek black people very
well either yeah and i let that be known
you know because they're crying for
freedom and liberation for north korea
every [ __ ] day
you know but the korean church doesn't
cry for freedom liberation for the
people in our own country
yeah and then this guy started
talking about my grammar and my spelling
my voice you know this guy's a loser
yeah and i just had to go in and just be
like hey man i've
i met you once i've never actually hung
out with you or anything
hardly knows you could walk up to him
and choke him out with one yeah that's
how
feeble this human i had to tell him if i
ever see you
like in person to person we're gonna
have a [ __ ] problem
yeah like leave me alone either unfriend
me i don't give a [ __ ] or just leave me
and don't and don't talk to me
yeah like and what do you say blank
of course like because it got real yeah
or and then it was
like a few months ago actually
a few months ago he dm me
it was a legit apology oh my god that he
had grown up he was an
[ __ ] and he hopes we can friend but
the thing is too
at the same time like i still haven't
met you
i still don't know you dude and i really
don't care if we are like i'm thankful
that you're apologetic
is that the point of it i didn't really
reply because i was like i still don't
know you
yeah it's like i i just don't talk to me
yeah it's just i'd rather if i don't
even talk to you ever
then nothing else this kid was so odd he
was so odd he was too old for that [ __ ]
too at the time
this podcast is brought to you by junebe
matcha do you
hate the jitters and crash that coffee
gives you well say
no more my friends because hundreds of
thousands of people are drinking jun b
matcha not only for the health benefits
but for the caffeine boost that lasts
without the crash of coffee you can mix
it
have it hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have
fun with it remember not all matcha is
created the same and junebe has the
highest quality matcha you can find
straight from a farm in japan
hand-picked and curated to get you the
best quality there is
no competition to get 10 off your first
order of tins and packets go to
junebeshop.com that's j-u-n-b-i
shop.com and enter code geniusbrain to
get 10
off your first order that's j-u-n-b-i
shop.com code geniusbrain he was not
good at what he did he was terrible
and that's what the person who he was
anyways it seems like he got a lot
better
but i don't really care for them dude i
i meet people like that where they know
they're in deep [ __ ]
but then they'll go ahead right
and like let's say two mutual people who
are working together a company i know
and
a person i know and this one person
who was on the verge of getting fired
came up to me and told me oh do you know
this person that works at that company
oh they're such a piece of [ __ ] they do
this and
and all this [ __ ] and then she's
like yeah i'm leaving i'm thinking i'm
leaving the company
and then on the other side of the this
you know the story you hear oh
they're terrible this person was a
terrible employee yeah and they're just
creating drama and talking [ __ ] about
everyone that was unnecessary
you know and didn't get the work done
because of it you know
let me tell you this [ __ ] funny ass
story so i i know somebody who owns a
business right
and one of the the hardest part about
the hiring process when you own a small
business right i'm not a part of the
hiring process in our own small
businesses but
this person was telling me because she
deals with the employees that
uh the generation that she's employing
now are very entitled
in the most in the most ridiculous way
possible right and by the way this lady
is not
my my friend who owns it she's not old
right she's
low 30s so she's not that far off from
like somebody who's like 25 26 24.
yeah and so one of the employees came in
and she goes this is what i have to deal
with this employee came in and said
hey uh oh this is this employee came in
an hour late to work
right and they're wondering what the
hell happened because
they she now has to ask another employee
to cover for the hour until she comes in
because she needs the help because
that's what they set the schedule up
with
they don't have that many employees
there so she comes in
and she goes hey you're an hour late
today
she goes yeah i just i was feeling sad
today
i'm excuse me she goes and you know
she's not
by the way she could she's very calm
doesn't yell at her she goes okay well
you know that even i understand that
you're sad
yeah we all have feelings you still have
to come to work
the fact that she had to tell her that
just because you're sad
you still have to come to work or she
told that you have to let us know what's
going on
now we had to ask x person to stay
behind to cover your shift and they have
somewhere to go do you think that's fair
and then she's looking at her like she's
crazy like what are you talking about
like
you guys don't care about mental health
it's no no my god
it's you haven't how frustrating is that
yeah you don't care about mental health
no it's fine
you had to let us know that something is
going on in your personal life and that
you might show up an hour late and you
didn't do that
so this girl continues with this
behavior and then she has to be let go
because she just decides to come
whenever she wants yeah so she goes out
of her way
goes on on their yelp and gives them a
one-star review talking about how it's
an abusive
uh abusive um workplace
a toxic workplace and so they had to go
on yelp and say well this is and they
shed a show
time cards this this employee showed up
multiple times late
and we let her go because of her
punctuality issues
so this is a disgruntled point so they
took the review down but that's somebody
who doesn't understand personal
responsibility
yeah i mean the entitlement goes a long
ways through
i don't know if it's a specific american
thing but god damn it i [ __ ] see it
so much here where they're entitled to
everything
they own everything and everything
should go towards them
people are entitled to to basic human
rights
you're not entitled for all these things
people think that their bonuses are
their basic rights
that's the crazy thing why is it called
a bonus thing
like they think that they're entitled to
praise for everything that they do
and it's completely [ __ ] obnoxious
and that's why they get hurt so much
they expect the world to always pat them
on the back and it's not true this is
not a younger generation this is even
our generation it's like this too
they they don't like criticism just like
that girl who who received the criticism
for the video
yeah she expect she asked you expecting
you to say that she was amazing and
because you didn't do it now it's your
fault that she quit
yeah not because she's weak not because
she's not good at her craft
not because she didn't want to put the
time and dedicate herself to something
because it's hard it's difficult growth
is difficult you never grow
from things being easy you grow from
[ __ ] adversity from failing
yes you have to fail to know what's
right yeah
yeah i think people just are repelled by
failure
and don't want to see it kind of thing
they want to see
like um they want to see quick results i
mean the same with like i mean
weight loss comes to mind too where they
think they're gonna have a six-pack in
two weeks or some [ __ ] yeah the next day
you know and it's okay to share these
flaws too that's why i'm okay saying
that i saw an old lady fall on the floor
and i
shadow boxes yeah
you can say what's wrong with you
yeah because you own it who the [ __ ] is
gonna say that against you you know it's
part of you
yeah i know you don't need to tell me i
know i know you know and this is just a
part of the process of growth man it's
it's hard to
that's why i like people who can laugh
at themselves because it shows that
somebody's willing to understand that
they have flaws and mistakes
laughing at yourself is one of the most
so satisfying
things ever because it takes power away
from other people who feel like they
could ridicule you right and it also
shows you that you understand what you
[ __ ] up and you can move on
and now like these younger generation is
trying to say self-deprecation isn't
funny
you know like i'm saying like it's toxic
towards this and that it's like come on
laughing at something
hating yourself through self-deprecation
is terrible yeah
laughing at your self-acceptation you
know we're not bullying yourself
you know what's toxic you being a little
[ __ ] yeah that's what's toxic you
little [ __ ]
it's like how [ __ ] dare you yeah
self-deprecating is the best man it
makes me
feel good because it allows me to laugh
at things that aren't important it's a
sign of intelligence
because you are aware exactly what
you're doing wrong
you know or what you did wrong and what
then
those type of people can assess how they
can be better in the future
yeah and it's just and i think
self-deprecation works on stuff that
just doesn't matter
it's stupid stuff that shouldn't bother
people right so for
i mean just watching the old lady fall
in shadow box it was pretty bad
that's pretty bad but i have to make fun
of myself because in that situation i'm
also kind of making fun of myself about
how much i had to second-guess myself
yes and the next thing you know
30 minutes later i'm like i should help
her and she's gone
she probably went to the hospital
you know i mean to to speak on your
failures to see what you missed
right and to see the humor out of it
is let's say it's a coping mechanism
mechanism right
it's better than hating yourself oh a
hundred percent
yeah to say you [ __ ] up i should have
done this i shoulda
whatever nah next time you know you'll
do better
you won't [ __ ] up nice you won't have
another story yeah you know like i
already have two stories of trying to
punch people in the face [ __ ] up you
know
even though i saw one of them yeah and
i'm telling you guys
i [ __ ] up because i was a [ __ ]
idiot right and it's real [ __ ] and
obviously why am i saying it out loud
i'm different now
yeah i would never do that now yeah
[ __ ] 35
now yeah you know it's way beyond that
yeah i wonder why why is that there are
so many weird trends now
where they feel like everything we did
in the past is toxic
and it's not true i think what's toxic
is people
subscribing to the fact that being weak
about everything is okay
it's close to trying to be holy and
perfect that's why i keep saying
wokeness is a theology
because they're striving for a holiness
this thing set apart from what society
is today
that's a standard that you can never
live up to because the biggest
difference between the people that you
are damning is the fact that their
information is public and yours is not
and that's your saving grace because i
wanted to dig into your [ __ ] closet
i'll see so many skeletons
it's unreal everyone has [ __ ] that
they're not going to say
yeah and i'll tell you this too i'm
actually okay with people saying [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in their small circles
as long as they don't teach their kids
that as long as they don't spread to
other people
right right you can have your own little
[ __ ] up jokes and your sense of humor
just don't bring it to anybody else and
don't teach it to someone you're not
gonna like put in public say it out loud
in a safe way or some [ __ ] yeah
and that's you're right you're allowed
to say it i think that's where the
freedom of speech
maybe they people got lost maybe the
world they lost
the fact that the world is not an open
mic yeah
that's what it is man yeah they think
the world is open yeah you couldn't say
anything yeah
twitter is an open mic isn't it yeah and
they think the world is an open mic now
and they could say whatever the [ __ ]
they want without any consequences and
when they get socked in the mouthway
they get surprised they go why did you
do that yeah you impeded on my rights
yeah how dare you that you get arrested
at [ __ ] uh nordstrom rack
yeah trying to cite uh the cdc
you [ __ ] weirdo well [ __ ] well we
forgot to talk about tennant again again
that's the second time
you know what this is what happens when
you have two guys with 80d yeah
we literally said all right we're
talking about tenant right and then we
took a water break
all right let's talk about tenant you
brought up tenant earlier today
we still went off [ __ ] rails dude
we'll get there
okay we'll get there eventually guys
either way this podcast was great
uh you guys could catch ed at ed park
vp and check his podcast at uh bible
study at momo yeah you can check them
and you can see every genius brain every
thursdays and sundays write in the
comments below if you're watching this
on youtube
about what you think about these topics
write down topics that you want to hear
and then we'll see you all next time
my [ __ ] uh brain farts brain farts
that's what you guys are our subscribers
baby see y'all next time peace